This is a super fragmented environment.
Right?
Now, when every insurance company
is trying to do their own thing
and try to propose its own model
and it's not unified and it's not tapping
into the same data feeds and incentives
and it's so fragmented, there's no way
something meaningful can happen
Oron Afek,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm good, Michael.
Thanks for having me here.
So, two really interesting things
to start off.
First of all, you're in Wyoming, right?
Even though you're based
out of San Francisco.
Yeah, yeah.
What is that about?
After corona started,
my wife and I decided to just, you know,
take this journey
and start working remotely
from multiple places.
And I've been living in the US
for seven years now.
And it's the first time I actually
experiencing it from the ground,
instead of from the air.
You know, those little,
20 minute trips from the airport
into a meeting back to the airport.
It's for the first time
I can experience the nature.
And Jackson Hole, Wyoming,
was one of the more attractive
destinations for us to spend some time.
So, trying to work from the road now.
And it's been amazing.
I love it.
So, just as fascinating as that is,
you also do Ironman, right, yearly?
Yeah.
Trying to keep in mental shape,
and it comes with a physical requirement.
So, I try to,
I originally started to do it for
just for the challenge.
But over the time,
it's been like a mental therapy
and a great travel destination thing.
So, you know, I've been in New Zealand,
I've been in Mexico.
Places I wouldn't go otherwise
if I hadn't had
you know, an event.
It is unbelievable.
So, you know, for a lot of people
doing these Ironmans
are almost a full time job
because of how intense they are.
So, just for the ear,
tell me a little bit about
what is the distance for the
running, cycling,
and for the swimming portions?
Yeah.
Well, the folks are doing it
full time job,
actually good athletes are.
I don't consider myself a good athlete.
I just do it for the sport.
So, the distances would be, you know,
3.8 kilometer swim,
followed by 180 kilometer bike ride,
and with a marathon finish.
So, it's pretty intense.
It sounds very, very intense.
And I'm sure that just as intense
as the Ironman experience,
is running a startup in the health space
and med tech space is just as intense.
So, tell me a little bit about
about what VIM is,
the company that you're
currently running.
Yeah. Sure.
So, VIM is something we started back
in 2015,
you know, maybe a year or longer,
if you consider the time
it takes to plan and to get ready
to get a company funded
and get off the ground.
VIM is a operating system
for health care networks.
So, we operate solely
in the United States,
which is a story
by itself how we got here
and how we started this thing here
in the US, a bunch of Israelis.
But think about it this way.
In Israel, we have two
or three large HMOs,
health maintenance organizations
like Maccabi, Leumit,
and so on and so forth,
similar to Kaiser, maybe here in the US.
Fully integrated payer
and medical provider
are part of the same entity.
So, full alignment of interest.
And everything is very streamlined.
The physician would like to see you
to prevent costs from happening.
In the US, it's kind of different.
The system here was established
as a fee for service system.
So, it's what you would maybe know
from a world of lawyers or accountants,
you know, people that would bill you
by the hour, time and material, right?
So, physicians here actually
have the wrong incentive, in my opinion.
Which is, you know,
treat you when you're sick.
There is a lack of incentive
of keeping you healthy.
There's an incentive to render more care
when you're getting sick.
This also is driven because of this
separation or
the institutional separation
between the payer and the provider.
So, you have insurance companies
on one end,
Unitedhealthcare, Cigna
and so on and so forth,
and you have medical providers.
In your case,
you're probably very familiar
with Stanford, Sutter Health
and all those guys.
So, basically the separation between
church and state is actually not good
in healthcare.
A dismissal of incentive,
given that physicians are actually
charging on a fee for service basis,
hence they render more care,
they're getting paid more.
And the insurance companies would like
to get to pay less
to maintain profitability.
And that inherent conflict of interest
combined with the IT fragmentation
is a huge problem resulting in this
almost four trillion dollar cost.
Which is three times more per capita
than any other OECD country.
So, what VIM does in all this chaos,
By the way, Oron, you know,
while we're saying this, you know,
I understand the magnitude
of what you're saying,
and while you're talking about this,
all I'm thinking about is that at VIM,
you have millions of Americans
at the end of the day
through all of this,
you know, misalignment,
and through all this disincentives
that we're introducing into the economy,
we have millions of Americans that just
don't have proper health benefits
and they don't get taken care of
when they need.
They get sick when they
don't need to get sick.
And when they do get sick,
they can't pay the bills.
And so, obviously, you know, on one hand,
a lot of people are going out
and they're solving these
trillion dollar problems,
that of misalignment in the economy.
But what you're doing here,
even more than that,
you're actually working on
on improving people's lives.
Which not every startup can come and say
that you're directly impacting
whether a person perhaps lives or not,
or gets to get treatment
when they do get sick.
So that's just, to put in perspective,
it's a huge problem.
I believe more than half of Americans
don't have $400
in their bank accounts to pay
in the case of emergency.
And so, you know, it's even greater
when it's a fee for service
type of model.
But sorry. Go ahead.
No. I appreciate you
mentioning the saying.
You know, it's easy to forget sometimes
that we're doing something
that is very special
and helpful for people.
And, you know, myself and the company
in particular, are very driven people.
And we're doing it, first and foremost
to make a difference,
not for economical reasons.
We truly believe there is a huge
financial opportunity
side by side with fixing the system
just by taking the excess cost
out of the system.
Yeah.
So, it's incredible.
And you mentioned 50% of Americans
have less than $400
or less available cash
in their account at any given time.
Take this into consideration
with the huge deductibles
that people need to pay
before their insurance even kicks in.
Because during the past 15 years,
there was a huge shift
to cost to the patients, right?
So, insurance companies would just
be puzzled of how they're going to pay
those bills and say, let's prevent people
from using the health care
in the first place by shifting more costs
and making you responsible,
so they stop being opportunistic.
So, the average family deductible
is now 3500 bucks
for a year, per year.
And with 400 bucks for 50% Americans,
it means no access to health care.
So, I mean, look,
we can't do everything we want, right.
So, VIM had to focus on one area
where we can actually, make a difference.
So, what we've been focusing on
the past five years is actually
building this connectivity tissue between
insurance companies and physicians.
Now, physicians is not a physician,
so you have like
maybe a thousand different,
we call them EMRs,
electronic health records or
electronic medical records, you know,
those old operating system
that sit on those provider offices
and maintain the data
and help to prescribe drugs
and so on and so forth.
And obviously billing.
Which is the main function
of those systems.
And those systems
don't talk with each other,
and they don't talk
with the insurance company.
So, we make them all talk
and enable ease of access to data
and ease of transfer of data.
And what we believe
this is going to become,
we believe it's going to become
the operating system of the network
of health care and thus become the
the ground work or the infrastructure
for value based care.
What is value based care?
It's a world where incentives
are aligned between
insurance companies and physicians.
So, doctors are rendering care
in order to get you healthier.
And they're actually enjoying the
downstream cost savings of your health.
That's what they actually monetize,
not the individual service.
So, think about a physician
who is incentivized to render better care
and for your long term benefit
in keeping healthy.
That's how she's actually
making money downstream,
not from rendering more care,
but by rendering less care.
And to actually make this happen,
you need connectivity,
you need data to flow,
you need incentives to flow.
And that's what VIM does.
VIM is building this operating system
to enable value base care.
And we are very passionate about it.
So, I'm deeply curious
about what you're saying.
I just need another explanation here
just to make sure I fully understand.
So, how do you change the alignment
so that a physician doesn't get the value
from the service, but gets a value
from the patient's well-being?
How does that work?
I understand the connectivity between
the systems and the fact that you need
some sort of operating system
to handle all that communication
across the board.
But how does that change
the incentive of the physician
versus the insurance company?
Because today, swiping the credit card
happens at the time of the ailment.
Right?
Yeah. Absolutely.
So it's a really good question, Michael.
So, I think the rule of thumb is
is in one word is, capitation.
If you think about a doctor
in Israel or Australia or in the UK,
whatever single payer system
you can think about,
they're getting a salary.
And that salary is adjusted in accordance
with the number of patient they see.
So, think about moving to a similar model
where the primary care physician,
the GP, the person who are managing
your total health, she's making a PMPM.
Per member per month fee.
Let's say she's making 600 bucks
per month for the patient's health.
Right?
If it's an older patient,
let's say that they consume more care.
If it's a younger patient, maybe 250,
300 bucks a month for the patient's care.
Right?
So, she's getting that.
And she is responsible for the total cost
of care of that patient.
Wow.
So, from now on,
she becomes a mini insurance company.
And on the back end,
you have infrastructure supporting
stop loss and other things.
You guys may be familiar
in your other day job that you guys
are thinking about all day
how do you ensure
the insurance companies, right,
and so on and so forth.
But assuming she has this
infrastructure behind her,
she's basically able to be
rendering more care
to prevent downstream cost.
And she's fully incentivized to do so
because she's getting that PMPM.
By the way, it's amazing
because think about coronavirus,
those physicians been struggling
with having office visits
and people come to them.
They've been losing
most of their business
in the first months of coronavirus
because people didn't show up.
They didn't go to see the doctor.
If the doctor gets paid PMPM,
it's getting paid whatever happens, right.
So, now you see this huge
willingness of doctors
to switch their model
into a PMPM capitated model.
So, that's an amazing thing
that happened in the past year.
So, that's what we also see a big growth
for our opportunity.
And then we have specialists.
The specialists are not
primary care physicians.
They don't need to think
about people's total health.
They need to think about specific
condition and procedures to render.
And so, there's a different type
of capitation that may happening
for specialists.
I think about it as bundle payments.
So instead of let's say
someone is giving birth
and seeing a 300 page bill
with three thousand line items that say,
that breaks down the anesthesia
and the hospitalization
and the consultations and the MRIs
and the CT-scans and the ultrasounds
and whatever happens
in that specific episode,
instead you have a surgeon who would say,
I'm going to do this delivery
in $30,0000.
Whatever happens, happens.
And I'm responsible
for total cost of care for that episode.
So, if you cap the PCP, the primary care,
the GP on a per member per month basis,
and you cap a specialist
on an episode basis,
you can really form a marketplace, right,
of value based care.
You stop paying for services.
You're paying for people's health
by incentivizing
in their own a per service basis capped or
on a per member per month basis capped.
You incentivize the individuals
to just do what's good for the system.
And I believe you see,
I actually believe it's the,
and it's a longer conversation
than 20 minutes,
but I believe it's actually the answer
for other health systems like
Israel and the UK and Australia,
where the single payer system
is bankrupting because of over demand
for private services.
So, I actually think this can solve
all the Western world problems.
If we can actually build this model.
Oron, how do you get to educate
a new market in health
and creating a new economy
between customer, patient,
doctor relationship and insurance,
that whole triangle?
You know, this is something that the US
has been dealing it with for many years.
Obama, obviously, put it
at the forefront of his campaign,
this idea of how do we provide
accessible health care.
We've seen the disastrous rollout
of Obamacare very unfortunately,
because I think it served
a fantastic purpose
of fundamentally allowing people
access to health care,
which you're giving that same access,
but in a different, and perhaps,
even more meaningful way.
What leads you to go
and create this whole
new economy and new marketplace
for doctors, for physicians,
insurance companies and patients?
Yeah.
I think these are two great question.
So, the first question, maybe,
I'll start with answering this
like what's different in what we do.
Because it's obviously the approach
I'm presenting is not my idea.
People have been thinking about it
for 50 years now.
But I think there's something different in
what we do over what we've done before.
And the second question is like,
why are we doing it.
Why we approach this problem
and what kind of motivated.
So, let me answer
the first question first.
So, you know, I mean,
every physician in the United States
is on average, is contracted with,
you know, one large federal insurance,
usually Medicare, purely responsible
for 50% of my business as a doctor.
And then another
20 or so insurance companies,
commercial insurance companies,
some of them are seeing
Medicare advantage,
some of them seeing commercial population
like large employers, whatever,
this is a super fragmented environment.
Now, when every insurance company
is trying to do her own thing
and try to propose its own model,
and it's not unified
and it's not tapping into the same
data feeds and incentives
and it's so fragmented, there is no way
something meaningful can happen.
And the doctors not adopting
those offerings because they only apply
for a small subset of their patients.
What VIM does is that we aggregate
those insurance companies.
And we're proud to have to serve
the largest insurance companies
in the United States.
So, think about Anthem,
UnitedHealthcare,
those two companies alone have almost
a hundred million Americans
covered under them. Right?
And you're probably familiar with both.
And we cover additional ones.
So, I think as an aggregator
of insurance companies,
we're actually able to represent
a bigger portion of membership
and talk with physicians
in a way that it appeals to them
to really change behavior
and alter the incentives
and so on and so forth.
As per the second question is,
I guess, it's a more difficult question.
What led us to start.
So, I can personally speak for myself.
My co-founders can tell their own story.
Yael and Asaf,
will be delighted to be on your show.
But my personal story is just frustration.
Pure frustration
from my own personal career.
I was actually very much enjoying
my time in the military.
I feel I'm contributing.
I feel like I'm making a difference.
And then, you know,
when I started to become an entrepreneur,
basically, I never really worked
for a company.
I was trying to start my own thing.
And I think the two main companies
I was involved,
one is in the telecommunications space
selling to large mobile operators.
And the other one is in the gaming space
selling to big gambling,
online gaming companies.
And not to discount any of the values
of those two areas
are driving for the world.
I haven't felt fulfilled and driven
doing those things.
I felt like the economical impact
on my personal life
was pretty much gone after I made,
you know, I would say a little,
a little pocket of change that I could
afford to pay rent and maybe some more.
And I felt like that's not really
making any more difference for me.
I'm trying to really think about
something that will make a difference.
And the first thing,
it wasn't health care.
The first thing was I want to start
a business with mechanics
that I'll be passionate about.
And I put a spreadsheet and I said,
this will exercise, you know,
if I could start any type of company,
10 years ago,
what I would start in the names
on the spreadsheet were
Amazon and Uber and Airbnb.
And, you know,
it wasn't Google, it was Apple.
It wasn't any of these. Right?
And I was thinking,
what is the common denominator.
And I saw that marketplaces
is what I'm really passionate about.
I started reading everything
about marketplaces,
including the Everything Store,
which is the Amazon early book
that really inspired a lot
of what you see in them
from my standpoint.
And so, you know, as a frustrated
builder with a hammer looking for a nail,
I was looking for my marketplace
to be built and Obamacare
was starting to emerge back in 2014.
And it looks such a natural,
natural place for me to try something.
Right.
So, it's like huge variation of cost
with no difference in quality.
It's like retail 25 years ago.
Right.
I mean it's just amazing opportunity.
And cost and quality variation
in healthcare is the biggest disparity
in everything else in the world.
I mean, US healthcare is the most,
the biggest market with variation
that you can ever imagine.
So, I thought it's a great opportunity.
And I didn't know anything
about health care back then.
I don't think I know too much today.
But I think I know a little bit more.
And I feel very lucky to stumble upon
this amazing opportunity
in an industry and people.
And it's been fun.
I think it's fascinating
and it's inspiring for me to hear
about the shift in you.
And sort of self responsibility
that you took over
your own contentedness, happiness
and satisfaction and fulfillment, right?
I mean, I believe that
they've done multiple studies on happiness,
and satisfaction levels of people.
And multiple levels of satisfaction
and fulfillment of people.
And they found that there is the,
as you approach, I believe,
80 or $90,000 a year salary,
it's actually like a logarithmic curve.
Your happiness shoots up
as you are able to feed your family
and pay your rent.
But then as you reach that
80, 90, 100,000,
it starts leveling out.
And then the extra money doesn't actually
make a difference in fulfillment.
And that's where you go
and you find your passion.
And I just love that.
Oron, thank you so much
for being on the show.
Thank you for being
so generous with your time.
This was inspiring for me
and it's inspiring me
and hopefully my friends as well
who are listening to this
to go and tackle these big, big problems
that are both very
economical for a startup,
but also just a huge impact
on people's lives.
But before we go,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And the hardest question.
Yeah.
Well, you know, the first one is easy.
I think I'm pretty driven.
You just described why.
And I think it's a really
good description.
I'm really not motivated by money.
I'm motivated by impact.
I think I rediscovered myself.
I'm 38 now.
So, I rediscover myself in the age of 30.
The second one is
fortunately or unfortunately,
I'm pretty optimistic.
So, I need to try and see the horizon,
the full picture
and what's going to happen
and try to believe in this
and try to be part of that.
I am truly optimistic
the US healthcare system
is going to change because
if it's not going to change,
we're going to have a 20% GDP problem,
kind of problem
emerging in the next couple of years.
It's ridiculous, right?
So, something need to change.
So, hopefully to be
in the right set of a change.
The third one is pretty tactical, I think.
I think I'm pretty decisive.
So, I mean, there is an unlimited
number of literature, pages, articles,
people you can speak
with in this industry.
And it's not never going to be enough.
And I think just me coming
from a place of zero knowledge,
don't know what I don't know.
In the long term my co-founders
and we try to make a difference
in this industry, decisiveness
is a really important feature.
And I think those three maybe describe me
at least in 2020,
or in the past seven years,
they describe me pretty well.
I love it.
Oron, thank you very much. Toda raba.
Enjoy the rest of your time in Wyoming.
Thank you for making an impact
in a lot of people's lives.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
You too, Michael. Thanks man.